read the question carefully with me it
tells you everything you need to know
from four boys and five girls two
children are chosen at random to
represent the school
draw a tree diagram to determine the
probability
of choosing at most one girl
okay so
you can see i've already constructed my
beginning here right now despite the
fact that there are nine people in this
situation you do not need to draw nine
branches every time there's only two
possible
possible outcomes in each stage of
choosing a student
there are either a girl or a boy okay
and once you choose a girl there are
still more girls and boys to choose so
i get all of these different outcomes
down here
okay now the tricky part of a
probability tree diagram
is to make sure you get the
probabilities on each of the branches
correct
so what's the probability of picking a
girl the first time five
out of the nine and because this is nice
and neat i only got two each time
the other one's just the compliment so
it's just four over nine
okay but then you keep on thinking as
you go through
from the top having selected a girl the
first time
two things have changed number one the
number of girls has changed so it's no
longer
five it's four and secondly the total
number of students you can choose from
there's also change
so this is now eight which means that
this is the compliment
so that's fine in exactly the same way i
now think about the boys
the number of girls hasn't changed but
the number of boys
has okay so i finished my
diagram you could add one more thing to
this sometimes this is very useful
depending on what kind of question
you've got uh remember i said before if
there's a small number of possible
events
just list the things out it won't take
you long and it will help you answer the
question
accurately right so i'm just going to
write letters that correspond to each of
the events
so girl girl girl boy and
so on okay now the question
what is the probability of choosing at
most one girl at most one girl
so how many different ways can i do this
at most one girl
so so clearly one girl is okay because
that was one girl
so so these each have one girl
um if i go this round have i chosen at
most
one girl yeah the answer is i have
right because zero girls are still less
than one girl right
so this is an okay option now having to
tick these all off you can see
i've got two options now right i can
multiply through get this one
multiply through get this one multiply
through get this one and add them all up
or maybe and again the second place has
helped me see
if i just work out what this one is then
the probability i'm after all of these
guys
is one take away the probability
of two girls that's clearly a more
efficient way to do this
yeah uh you should get the same answer
either way so
i'm going to write this i suppose i
could have said the probability of
at most one girl
like that is that this one girl yes it
is okay
so i'm gonna do one take away and you
can see i'm gonna multiply along the
branches to get the top one right
so this is one take away this
times this
um four does four go into that
four goes in right is there a big enough
therefore
it's four right so this is five over 18.
so that's that are you happy with that
yeah
in a similar way to what i've pointed
out before right as we went through
calculus you started to say oh i focus
on the rules and
you know executing properly but then as
you apply it
you think less about the rules and more
about well how am i going to use these
which rule should i use
and it's exactly the same thing here the
math is super easy
it's about how you employ that and what
tools you use to get to that one
okay right last question last question
and then i'll set you to work on
these exercises that will get you more
practice um we've got these 12
friends who are having a merry time okay
yeah i gave you a table at the beginning
which asian principles look at the
question
what tool will you use to help you
understand okay i'm going to use a venn
diagram because
people are clearly able to do more of
these
things at the same time than just one
okay
so that'll be enough space
here's my venn diagram
it's um also helpful it's not always
relevant but it is also helpful to put a
box around this
because there might be people who aren't
in either of these groups that i'm about
to identify
what are the groups okay
so just by labeling these in the way
that i've done
it kind of implies that the people
outside them haven't eaten neither of
those which is fine
okay so then you say
for the numbers that i've been given
where how do i start off
actually filling in numbers in here okay
okay so have a look right one had
neither beef nor apple pie
one okay so now i have a count in my
head right
there how many people in total 12 so
that means i've got 11 left to deal with
11 left to deal with okay now tell me
another number
okay okay so eight people ate beef right
eight b so there are eight people in
this circle but how many did i have left
in my count
i had eleven so if eight are here that
means
three have to be here do you see where i
got that number from
that number is implied it doesn't say in
the question
three people only sorry three people ate
only apple pie but by crunching from
this number
and what's happening in this circle the
three is where that that's where that
comes from
now once i've got that you see here
don't guess
think think have the count in your hair
okay now that i know there are three
here
okay so it says seven eight apple pie
well i've already counted three of them
so that means there must be four who i
haven't counted
which means that lastly remember before
there are eight people in this whole
circle
done okay so the hardest part of this
was just constructing knowing where the
numbers are going rather than
doing it my childhood